the first step for manifesting something
better is to forget about manifestation
and be completely concerned with the
present moment only and give your
fullest attention to the present moment
that includes not only whatever is
happening around you at the present
moment right now you hold your sense
perceptions and so on it also concerns
the thoughts that you're going through
your mind at the present moment so
there's a huge difference between having
thoughts go through your mind and being
aware that certain thoughts are going
through your mind at the present moment
this is something very important easy to
overlook thoughts go through your mind
all the time for most people
particularly people who have not
awakened yet in any way who are still
unconscious for those people there's no
awareness behind the thought this is why
we say they are unconscious hey it's
Evan Carmichael and I make these videos
because of my first business I quit I'm
a business partner I struggle to keep
going I was making 300 bucks a month and
felt like a complete failure and the
thing that saved me that pulled me up
was studying the stories of famous
entrepreneurs I got the motivation from
them I also got the strategies of what
to do next so that I can go off and
achieve my dreams and quite honestly I
still need the stories today myself to
continue my motivation to take it to the
next level so today let's learn how to
let go and let the universe draw things
to us enjoy
without awareness there's only the
movement of thought and the movement of
thought reacts to whatever is happening
around you and the way in which the
movement of thought reacts to whatever
is happening around you depends on the
way in which your mind has been
conditioned by past experiences so the
conditioning of your mind determines how
you react to things that are happening
around you how you interpret them
what kind of narrative you create around
what's happened what is happening around
you you you you ex you talk to yourself
that's the voice in the head the thought
process is
this talking to yourself becomes a
narrative
without awareness
you are completely identified with the
stream of thinking that is reactive to
whatever is happening around you
and if something is happening that is
challenging in other words some kind of
adversity limitation loss or disruption
of your life
the the normal thing for most people is
a a very uh scary narrative that arises
in your minds the way in which you
interpret what's happening is scary
because you're not only looking at
what's happening now you're also
extrapolating from there and saying how
is this going to affect me how is it
going what's going to happen tomorrow
next week is the future you project
yourself into the future with you see
things are getting even worse than they
are now you see already how whatever is
happening now how it's going to affect
your life and you play out scenarios in
your mind
which are not pleasant and you don't
know what you're doing you believe that
what you're experiencing is the reality
but it's not the reality what you're
experiencing is what your mind has
created it is a narrative that your mind
has created
as a reaction to what's happening around
you so you're not experiencing really
you're not experiencing reality you're
confusing
what is happening in your mind with
reality
uh so once an awareness comes in the
awareness another word for it is
presence when awareness comes in you
suddenly become aware of the kind of
thoughts that your mind is creating
and that's that is the beginning of
Awakening Spiritual Awakening The
Awakening of consciousness
that is to become aware of the way in
which your mind functions and what it
says and that this is why it's so
important uh
to become conscious of the present
moment because that is
an intrinsic part of the being present
is to become aware of what your mind is
doing in this moment and this is why I
said
first the first step is to forget about
wanting to manifest something different
we can go there later the first step is
become more intensely more acutely aware
of the present moment because if you are
not
if you're not without that awareness
you are at the mercy of your mind the
conditioned mind
without even knowing it you have become
a victim of your mind
and so it is true to say that for many
people
their worst enemy lives between their
two ears
without and they don't know it
so the most foundational
step is
coming into the present moment
which implies
the arising of awareness or presence
and asset awareness arises
you become aware not only of of your
immediate surroundings which which is
part of the present moment
but you also become aware of the
thinking mind and what kind of what
thoughts is your mind producing rule
number two is do less with Joe dispenser
in their Quantum there's nothing
structural there's nothing material
there's nothing physical there's no form
right so what is it made of it's made of
energy frequency vibration
thought Consciousness information and
every thought in that realm has a
frequency so all possibilities already
exist you don't have to create the
possibility in fact all you have to do
is become aware that exists
the moment you do that you you're
changing the thought and you're
producing a different frequency now if
the person is astute enough to feel the
frequency of the thought in the quantum
and not wait for the experience to
happen but the thought of abundance
would produce the feeling of abundance
for most people in three-dimensional
reality the thought of abundance
produces the lack of not having it
that's why they're trying to create it
right but in the quantum you got to feel
it in order to experience it okay so as
you get closer and closer to that point
that source that Singularity pure love
the zero point field whatever you want
to call it universal mind that the
Creator pure Consciousness as you get
closer and closer to it
the closer you get to it the more bliss
the more love the more the more
um
ecstasy you feel uh then you're not no
longer creating from lack or Separation
The Closer you get to it in the process
of creation the shorter the distance
between the thought of what you want and
the experience of having it between the
cause and the effect from one point of
Consciousness and the other point of
Consciousness so then people can create
from the field instead of from matter
if they have a coherent brain and a
coherent heart and they actually can
send the coherent signal out and feel
the emotion ahead of the experience
then those synchronicities and
opportunities that they're creating from
fifth dimensional reality requires doing
less somehow it's drawn to us or it
comes to us it comes in ways that we
least expect that surprises us like whoa
where did that come from and now what
does that do it proves to you that
you're the creator of your life that
instead of the victim of your life rule
number three is be honest on all levels
with Louise Hay honesty is a word we use
a lot not always understanding the true
significance of what it means to be
honest
it has nothing to do with morality or
being a goody goody being honest really
has little to do with getting caught or
going to jail
it is an act of love for ourselves
the main value of honesty is that
whatever we give out in life we will get
back
the law of cause and effect is always
operating on all levels
if we belittle or judge others then we
too are judged
if we are always angry then we encounter
anger wherever we go
the love we have for ourselves Keeps Us
in tune with the love life has for us
for instance imagine that your apartment
has just been burglarized do you
immediately think that you're a victim
my apartment was just ripped off who did
this to me
it is a devastating feeling when
something like that happens
however do you stop to think of how and
why you attracted the experience
again taking responsibility for creating
our own experiences is not an idea that
many of us want to accept all the time
perhaps just some of the time
it is so much easier to blame something
outside of ourselves
yet our spiritual growth cannot occur
until we recognize that there is little
of value outside of us everything comes
from within
when I hear that someone has just been
robbed or experienced some kind of loss
the first question I ask is
whom did you steal from lately
if a curious look comes over their face
I know I have touched a tender spot
if we think back to a time when we took
something and then think of what we lost
shortly thereafter the connection
between the two experiences can be an
eye-opener
when we take something that isn't ours
we almost always lose something of
greater value
we might take money or some object and
then we might lose a relationship
if we steal a relationship we might lose
a job
if we lift stamps and pens from the
office we might miss a train or a dinner
date
the losses almost always hurt us
in some important area of Our Lives
it's unfortunate that many people steal
from large companies department stores
restaurants or hotels and so on
rationalizing that these businesses can
afford it
this type of rationalization does not
work the law of cause and effect
continues to operate for each one of us
if we take we lose if we give we get it
cannot be otherwise
if there are many losses in your life or
many things are going wrong you might
examine the ways in which you are taking
some people who would not dream of
stealing things
will self-righteously rob another person
of time or self-esteem
each time we make another person feel
guilty we are stealing self-worth from
them
to be truly honest on all levels takes a
great deal of self-examination and
self-awareness
when we take something that does not
belong to us we are in effect
instructing the universe that we don't
feel worthy of earning we aren't good
enough we want to be stolen from or we
believe there is not enough to go around
we believe that we must be sneaky and
grab to get our good
these beliefs become effective walls
around us that prevent us from
experiencing abundance and joy in our
lives
these negative beliefs are not the truth
of our being
we are magnificent and deserve the very
best
this planet is abundantly plentiful
our good always comes to us by the right
of consciousness
the work we do in Consciousness is
always one of refining what we say and
think and do
when we clearly understand that our
thoughts create our reality then we use
our reality as a feedback mechanism to
let us know what we need to change next
being absolutely honest down to the last
paper clip is a choice we make out of
love for ourselves
honesty helps to make our lives run more
smoothly and more easily
if you go to a store and they don't
charge you for something you've bought
and you know it
then it's your spiritual obligation to
tell them so
if you are aware you call it to their
attention if you don't know it or only
realize it when you get home or two days
later then that's something different
if dishonesty brings disharmony into our
lives imagine what love and honesty can
create
the good in our lives the wonderful
surprises we have these two we have
created
as we look within ourselves with honesty
and unconditional love we will discover
so much about our power also to make
sure you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number four is visualize with
Lisa Nichols how important you know I'm
a big believer in visualization and
obviously in the secret that's something
that was talked about I haven't watched
Secret in 10 years when it came out but
I mean this is something I practice as
an athlete to visualize my results
before the game would happen to see
myself scoring the touchdown in the
track meet and I'm sure you did a lot of
similar things how important is
visualization in abundance but then also
how important is taking action right so
I have five visualization exercises in
that book just because it's so important
visualization is a gift to your heart
and your soul it's a gift because if the
the idea
is the seed visualization is the is the
um it's the fertilizer it's the
fertilizer because when your thoughts
are connected with an emotion see you
would visualize yourself winning and you
would feel all the emotion that came
with that and all you're doing now is
you're not chasing a foreign emotion you
know the feeling and now you're just
doing what's necessary to get back to
that feeling in real time exactly and so
what what a good friend of mine vision
of the CEO of my value you know I would
I did a visualization with him we were
in Bali and
um he said to me afterwards I never get
emotional he does it he doesn't get
emotional right right yeah well he was
like I cried and I got emotional he goes
I figured it out it's visualization a
good visualization brings an emotion he
was like that's how you do it and so
um I I love doing visualizations because
and it's real important in the
visualization you can't see it over
there you have to see it right here feel
it you got to feel it right here like I
am it's all I am I am I am in my dream
home I am in my dream relationship and
then unpack what that looks like but
most importantly unpack what it feels
like and when you have that that emotion
in this moment all of a sudden you stir
up something that I don't think will
ever go back to sleep it'll go okay
let's go get that and what it really
does is it sets up a state of cognitive
dissonance and cognitive dissonance is
when you see something in your mind and
you see your yourself in a way that your
behaviors are not currently leading to
and so your mind becomes disrupted and
it goes okay can we get there right
because I'm not there right now I'm not
there right now and that's not
comfortable your mind wants to literally
be congruent what it thinks is what
you're doing what it thinks is what
you're doing and so when you set up a
constant and abundant thinkers like you
and I we do it unconsciously we we are
constantly keeping ourselves in a state
of cognitive dissonance meaning okay
what else and I'm seeing Lisa over there
and I'm going okay let me go wow while
being grateful for my now yeah it's not
in that I'm going to be whole and
complete when I get over there I'm
holding complete now I just know I'm
supposed to be over there so let me do
what's necessary to get over there and
let me let me evict any behaviors or
characteristics that are stopping me and
let me adopt any new ones that I need
rule number five is be conscious with
Bruce Lipton we talked about
electrophysiology reading the brain and
then Magneto and cephalograph where you
can read your brain function out here so
your thoughts are going out into the
field shaping the world okay so your
thoughts are not containing your head I
can read them out here with a with
Magneto and cephalograph you're like a
tuning fork okay
and you can generate any vibration you
want you're a generator of vibration an
energy from an astrological point of
view is an energy in the field yeah what
I say I can make an energy that will
enhance the existing energy
but I can also make an energy that
cancels an existing energy
I go what does that mean I said then all
of a sudden with more Consciousness your
astrology is not predictable anymore
because I can cancel an energy field
or I can take that field and make it
work even more powerful because it's
called constructive destructive
interference in physics where one energy
field can alter another energy field and
since we are broadcasting energy Fields
I am not a prisoner to environmental
energy Fields because I can send out an
energy to cancel it or an energy to
enhance it it's also called bad vibes
Good Vibes
and I can control that and all of a
sudden it says well yeah you're very
powerful but you have to be conscious if
you're unconscious you're totally
predictable by the astrology because the
field is going to override your ability
to to deal with that field and so it
says yeah the less conscious you are the
more predictable you are the more
conscious you are
free will start to step in and then you
can create what you want every
regardless of what the field is saying
that's powerful and all other organisms
on this planet are manifestation of the
existing field what day the swallows are
going to go back to Capistrano it's not
up to the swallows it's up to the field
one day the turtles are going to come
out on the beach and hatch the eggs and
all that that's on the field uh and but
when you get to humans
we have the ability to generate tuning
fork read the vibration out here to
generate energies that can enhance an
existing field or energies that can
cancel an existing field and all of a
sudden it says oh my God you're not
locked into the to the environment as
every other organism is you have free
will you can change the field so you're
changing the field from the inside with
your own biology but then you can change
it on the outside as well based on what
comes to you and I don't know if you
change it on the outside because
remember your thoughts are not contained
in here they're like a broadcast so
whatever outside fields are coming in my
inside Fields going back out can enhance
or
neutralize an existing field and rule
number six the last one before some very
special bonus Clips is focus on
positivity Rhonda burn question from
Instagram Rhonda how do you silence the
mind
Okay so
hopefully in my latest book I've helped
you do that
um because one of the ways to silence
the mind is to understand mind right is
to understand a lot more about it and in
the secret you've got to understand how
powerful it is in creating what you want
what you don't want but also it's
um it's also to understand it at a whole
different level at a far deeper level
and then you really it doesn't seem to
have the power over you when you know
more about it when you understand what
its tricks can be and I think I called
it a tripster or a something like that
what did I call it in the greatest thing
oh yeah I call it a troublemaker called
a troublemaker in the greatest thing
it's the greatest Creator but it also a
troublemaker because if it says anything
mean about you no no it's a troublemaker
so um yeah so you can
um
silencing your mind the first step to
getting a quieter mind is to get your
mind positive because then you and and
you you do that with the secret
obviously is to be positive and positive
just means your mind is thinking about
what you want and not about what you
don't want that's what's positive what's
positive because everybody wants
different things so
um and then in the greater secret you
understand a whole lot more about the
mind you know a lot of people have
meditated and I I
didn't do that kind of traditional
meditation you know where you sit there
quieting the mind
um I was more diligent with what
thoughts were in my mind and that they
were positive and that if a negative
thought came up that I really gave my
attention to and energized I would just
immediately
think the opposite thought and I would I
would say that's all three times in my
head against left the negative thoughts
so it didn't create anything
um so yeah I did it I didn't meditate
but what I did do is everything that's
in The Greatest Secret
um anything that I write
um and anything that we create at the
secret are all the things that I have
done that I absolutely know work and uh
and meditation if you're somebody who
loves meditation fantastic you know keep
doing it if it's working for you keep
doing it
um a lot of people find that when they
go to meditate that their mind just goes
crazy crazy and they're trying to
quieten their mind with their mind but
the thing is their mind's a bit of a
troublemaker and so when you're trying
to quieten your mind with your mind it's
really it's not easy you know I find
that if I take my attention off my mind
right and the mind goes into the
background so if I open my attention the
Mind goes into it stops litter stops
is your financial Governor holding you
back from doubling or tripling your
income in the next six to 12 months now
you may be asking John what in the world
is a financial governor and I'll explain
it this way
many years ago when the car companies
were Building engines that were faster
and stronger and more resilient cars
could go 200 250 miles an hour some
maybe even to 300 miles an hour but
because of laws in Europe and the in the
United States these Governors were put
on the engine so that the car even
though it can go faster and perform even
better it was limited to about 155 miles
per hour so here we are we have these
cars that can go extremely fast but for
obvious reasons to conserve on gas to be
able to have more safety on the roads
and to keep us generally all driving
around the same speed limit we created
these Governors to put on engines in
order to limit the speed at which the
car can go at well what does that have
to do with you earning more money you
accumulating more wealth and the answer
is everything
if you understand that you have a
conscious brain that wants to set goals
but you have a subconscious mind that is
going to limit your thoughts emotions
feelings and behaviors to what you are
governed by which is your subconscious
mind
then here's one of the things that we
have discovered
I make thirty thousand dollars a year or
fifty or a hundred or five hundred
thousand dollars a year or a million
dollars a year or more
their financial Governor is set at a
totally different setting than somebody
who's earning less so why does this make
a difference well it makes a difference
because there's a part of your brain
that chooses the goal that you want to
achieve and there's another part of your
brain that's responsible for everything
else your thoughts emotions feelings and
behaviors and so if you don't have
coherence between these two parts of
your brain if you don't know how to
remove the governor and reset it chances
are you're going to have goals and
dreams Financial ones and even lifestyle
ones that you're not going to achieve
not because you're not capable of doing
it it's just because you are wired set
conditioned programmed whatever you want
to call it to earn the income you're
earning right now and maybe a little bit
more each day each week each month
versus doubling or tripler quintuple
your income now let me give you a
different visual for this that'll
hopefully cement what I mean let's say
you're in a room that has a thermostat
in there and the thermostat is set to a
nice and comfortable 70 degrees and you
feel nice at that temperature what
happens if you open up a window and
let's say it's winter and cold air comes
in well what happens is the mechanism in
the thermostat that picks up what the
temperature is in the room picks up a
deviation that cold air has come in the
room and what does it do it sends a
signal through the electoral system for
the heater to go on so that the room
gets back to 70 degrees that's called a
cybernetic mechanism a control and
respond mechanism that occurs in
machines that we create them in or in
animals like us so whether it's hot air
coming into a room or cold air coming
into a room any deviation from the set
program activates the air conditioning
or the heat until the program and the
room are one and the same that is a
cybernetic mechanism as I mentioned and
here's what happens in US humans if
you're used to earning thirty thousand
or fifty thousand seventy five a hundred
or two hundred or more or you are used
to a certain lifestyle any deviation up
or down from that setting that comfort
zone that programming
kicks in your nervous system so that you
either turn up the Jets and earn more
based on what you're used to or if you
do really well for a week a month a
quarter you actually back off and
sabotage your success until you meet the
setting that you have in your mind that
is how a governor Works in a car that's
how a governor works in your brain so
if you want to double or triple your
income in the next six months 12 months
two years
doesn't it make sense that you should
reset your financial Governor the
expectation point the programming the
conditioning
well of course it does what I've seen in
my years of training whether it's sales
people or entrepreneurs or individuals
to make more money is the ones that
think that they could do it just by
gaining more knowledge
missed the point because as a part of
our brain that gains more knowledge but
doesn't change Behavior what you have to
do is reprogram your financial set point
your conditioning the expectation point
and when you do that and you create this
coherence between your goal and your
dream and your subconscious programming
that is when your behavior starts to
change that is when fears dissipate that
is when you stop procrastinating that is
when you take inspired action and you
don't sabotage the success that you are
achieving
so in order to achieve your goals and
dreams you have to reset your Governor
reset your financial thermostat your
beliefs affect your world do you believe
certainly affect your biochemistry I've
had women of 58 say could you make me
pregnant I go I know it's too late why
did you wait 30 years but the mind will
follow your instructions and it's very
important to give yourself the right
instruction of course there are limits
you can't tell yourself you're going to
be an astronaut and when people said I
want to be a millionaire like what are
you going to do to be a millionaire you
can't go wrong with sit at home and
that's the problem with the secret
attract Millions to you what are you
going to do for these ones I want to be
have a six-pack you do need to go to the
gym I want to have great health well
stop eating pizza and eat better food
but once you get the mind to want it
it's actually easy but when people say
to me I want to be a millionaire then we
tell them well any goal of significance
requires you to learn something new but
then they have a fear of learning and
and of course you're right then when
people come in and go I want this you
have to look at the blocks the number
one block is the fear of rejection if I
make it I might get rejected if I find
love they might leave if I may call that
money people won't like me anymore so
you've got to smash out of the ballpark
the fear of rejection you've got to
smash out the second belief that says
it's all easy I remember Luther Vandross
saying you know people say I'm an
overnight success I sang Jingles for KFC
for 12 years
it was a long overnight so you do have
to also have that desire
I mean for me you know I speak in public
I write books always aware that
somebody's going to hate your book I
don't like it I'm like oh that's okay
they can't reject me they might reject
my book most people happen to love them
but to get anywhere in life
you have to get over the fear of
rejection
because people think they're going to
die from rejection but they really don't
consistent action is the cure-all
whatever problem you have whatever issue
you're facing whatever big life you want
to create for yourself the way to get
there is not some giant
short burst of effort it's the daily
consistent grinding action that will
help you accomplish your goals people
look at my channel and
a lot of new people have joined over the
past number of years hey welcome boy
great to have you welcome to believe
Nation it's a positive happy place it's
great to have you here it's an honor to
be a part of your daily routine
if you go and look at my my channel my
main channel in the history it took so
many years guys so many years of just
making content and not seeing any
results
I took I forget what the number is it
took five years to get to 9 000
something subscribers and another five
years to get to almost 2 million
subscribers now we're sitting over 3
million subscribers Etc
I haven't missed
an upload every single day
for I don't know
eight years
something crazy like that
every day
I've made videos through
travel I've made videos through elect
electricity electricity outages I made
videos through breaking my neck I made
videos through my tour I made videos
through vacation I made videos I made
videos I made videos I made videos I
made videos I made videos and you can
plan you can prepare you can get ahead
you can you can batch them
but I don't think your goals count until
they're hard
it's when it gets hard when when you get
tested that's when you have to show
yourself What You're Made Of
even little things like
I remember filming at my dance studio in
Toronto
and I have my camera guy and my
assistant and we're filming and the
electricity goes out
and then there's a fire alarm
yo I guess we can't film like the first
thing that that my camera guy says is
okay well I guess we can't film I can't
film with this like electricity outage
and then fire alarm
you can't film with that it's like I'm
I'm filming today
so I took my phone it was freezing
outside I took my phone went outside and
just started filming
because videos have to go up
they have to go up
I've I've made videos with my broken
neck
I broke my neck in two spots had a
concussion
and I
next week I'm making videos
they weren't as long they weren't as
good
I'm wearing a neck brace if you look at
the old videos I'm wearing this giant
neck brace I got this giant scab here on
my forehead because I smashed my head
against the wall
when I fainted and that's how it led to
the concussion broken neck I'm still
making videos
not making videos is not an option
and so if you look at someone like me
who
is introverted is shy who doesn't like
the camera who always thought that
people who are famous had a big ego who
I still don't like being on stage I
still get nervous every single time
but I still have a message
and I still want to serve how does
somebody like that
have this kind of Channel well because
of every single day making videos you've
done over 10 000 videos I've done over
10 000 videos that's crazy
not all of them are public
but even just on the main Channel let
alone this channel on the top 10 channel
on the other channel 10 000 Plus videos
over 12 years
why
how
it's just a consistent action
I think most people lose because
we overestimate what we can do
in a really
short period of time and underestimate
what we can do in a long period of time
you think by putting in three weeks of
hard work you're gonna crush it
but really if you just stayed on it like
guys you've had ideas you have enough
you've you have had an idea that you'd
love that you gave up on too soon that
if you just kept doing it this is an
idea that you had maybe three years ago
that if you just found the way to keep
doing it even part-time even on the side
even on the weekends if you just kept at
it you'd be in a different place right
now
something would have happened something
would have paid off
but we're too frustrated to get
something to happen right now and I get
it I'm there too I'm I'm impatient I
want immediate results I want things to
happen I'm putting my best I want this
video right now to be the best one I've
ever done and I put my effort to try to
make that happen and I fully recognize
at the same time that
it's a long game
that you have to keep going
and that it's your purpose you can't
give up on it
most people just quit too soon
you just quit too soon
and that's you quitting on your dream
and if it's your dream and you want it
to happen it's a daily consistent I
action to make it happen
so how do you do it let me give you some
tactics so that you can not just get
motivated from a message but actually
apply it to your life number one you
have to create a calendar
these videos happen because they're in
my calendar
I'm filming this on a Tuesday Tuesday is
my YouTube day I always film on Tuesday
I block it off in my calendar
I just came back from vacation and on
the Tuesday of my week I was still
making videos people say well you still
work on vacation first off it's not work
like I like this this is fun for me this
isn't this isn't oh I have to go make
videos if that was my mindset I would
I'd be out I wouldn't do it anymore
but also if you're on vacation you're
making videos or you're doing a little
bit of work
spend three hours
of a 24-hour day
doing something
is totally achievable somebody one of
the people that I invested into
yesterday's like how do we take a
vacation on my business
like how do I my wife wants to know how
do I go on vacation and run this
business like you can still you can
either plan ahead and get ahead with all
your clients or you can still do some
work
do you not have personal time are you
going to be around your wife 24 hours a
day does your wife not want to go to the
spa or spend some time on the beach it's
not about the three hours that you spend
working it's about
the other hours at 21 hours you get to
sleep but whatever all the other hours
that you have the day it's about
intentional time most of most people's
life is not intentional most of your
vacation time is not intentional either
if you were to spend 21 hours a day with
your wife
intentionally creating an amazing
relationship
then the three hours a day you're going
to spend working
as easy as nothing
so of course you could take time off
but you have to put in your calendar
you have to create a calendar that makes
sense for you
schedule in when you're actually going
to make your dreams happen because
otherwise it's a dream I could say I
want to make YouTube videos but if it
was never my calendar guess what it
would never happen and this applies for
life too every uh every afternoon
at 2 30 I spend time with Nina with my
wife
we spend time in the morning I take an
intentional break at 2 30 we go to the
park we take we take the dogs with us
we we stay inside and just be together
if it's raining like we'll spend time
every day every weekday at 2 30 because
I want I wanted to spend more time with
Nina during the week weekends we're
basically all in on on the relationship
but the weekdays can be crazy you know
so we spend time in the morning we spend
time in the evening and I wanted to
spend
2 30. it's 25 minutes together but
intentional 25 minutes that intentional
25 minutes is worth more than three
hours of just sitting in front of a TV
that's not time together
you have a lot more time than you think
just not being intentional that's the
problem if you feel like you got to the
end of the week and you were so busy but
you got nothing done
and everything's falling apart you're
just not intentional with your time
so you schedule it in whatever you want
in a life whatever your dream life looks
like whatever your goals Ambitions
motivations are put in your calendar
two
be the person who follows through on
their calendar
stop letting yourself off the hook
for not following through on your
calendar
I'm a little tired today because we just
came back from our trip I'm a little jet
lagged from coming out from the West
I'm still making videos I'm still videos
have to be made they're going up like
when do you let yourself break
if it's in the calendar it has to happen
videos have to happen today I don't care
if I'm lying in bed I don't care I don't
care if I'm in the hospital I've made
videos from the hospital I don't care
where videos have to come up I don't
care if they're the best videos the best
with what I can make right now
if I'm tired they might be lower than my
standard
but it's the best of what I can make
right now if I'm in the hospital it's
definitely lower than what I can make
out of the hospital but I'm gonna make
the best of what I can make right now
be the person who follows through on the
things that you say you're gonna do
because the next time you put something
in your calendar the next time we see
you're gonna get that goal or
do this project you're gonna the next
day wake up and say I'm not there I
can't do that I'm not doing that
you're starting to build the identity
either way of the person who follows
through or the person who doesn't follow
through
and every time you say yes to yourself
every time you do it when it's difficult
you start to build up that identity a
little bit more I follow through I
follow through I follow through so then
the next time you put something in your
calendar the next time come up with a
goal you start to believe that it's
actually possible for you to do it
because you're building that identity of
you being the person who actually
follows through
and every time you let yourself off the
hook every time you give yourself a
break every time you say it's okay I'm
not going to do it today every time you
say that
you eat away at that other identity and
start to build a new one
the new identity of the person who
doesn't follow through
you start to believe yourself a little
bit less
the next goal you write down is a little
less credible you don't think you can do
it you're going to realize the next day
that you're not going to follow through
and so it's a very
slippery slope to fall down
so step one is you build a calendar step
two is you become the person who sticks
to your calendar
who follows through on the things that
you say you're gonna do that's why it's
important to create a realistic calendar
don't tell me don't tell yourself you're
gonna make 100 videos a day every day
you're going to make a thousand phone
calls a day every day
you're not you're gonna write a hundred
love letters to your wife every day
you're not you're not it's not going to
happen make it a realistic plan for
something you can actually stick to
because again if you just stick to it
guys you will hit your goals
if you stop quitting on yourself if you
stop letting yourself off the hook that
idea you had three years ago should have
already come to Creation because you
just stuck with it just stick with it
step number three so create a calendar
one stick to your calendar number two
three
the environment around you really
matters
videos like this really matters why I
create the inspressor to be with you
every morning to give you the Boost to
bring you people like John astraff and
Oprah and Elon Musk and these people who
lift you up who inspire you hopefully
that's the intention every time
join a group like movement makers be a
part of a community be around other
entrepreneurs who are doing things we're
chasing their dreams we're trying to
make their thing happen when you're when
you create that environment and you
start to shift it
it inspires you to want to play bigger
it inspires you to want to stay
consistent when you are feeling at your
lowest low when you're about to quit on
the thing that you said that you want to
do that's in your calendar you see it
you see it today I'm supposed to do that
like I don't want to do that what brings
you out of it
it's the habits it's the environment
it's the routine
watch another video
join our group like movement makers
get a mentor coach
have an accountability buddy
you have to be around the people who
constantly fill your cup who give you
light who lift you up who make you
believe and help you feel like it's
possible when you do those three things
your life will change
create a calendar
that mapped your actions
to your ambitions
be the person who follows through on
their calendar
and then be around the people videos
resources environment
that encourages you that lifts you up
and makes you feel like it's possible
when it comes to an affirmation
affirmations can be powerful uh
and for some people they're not
and a lot of people say well you know if
the the affirmation is so powerful how
come I'm not experiencing the effect the
what scientists tell us is the average
human
speaks to themselves consciously or
unconsciously we have thoughts spinning
around in our brain about 60 to 80 000
thoughts per day some of those thoughts
are the words to the songs and they are
the affirmations
uh neuroscientist Andrew nurburg tells
us Newberg is his name I'm sorry and um
in his work that that a single word a
single word has the power to to change
the genes that create stress or relieve
stress in our lives he's telling us that
that something within us has the ability
to shift at the very core of our
expression so we know that words are are
powerful the key to a successful
affirmation is that we must communicate
with the subconscious part of our of our
mind number one number two we must
communicate in the language that the
subconscious recognizes
and this is where uh you know you can
say
I had a friend of mine when I was
working in the corporations that had
affirmations all over his office all
over his computer screen they were on
little Post-it notes in the car we would
carpool in you know my Perfect Mate is
manifesting for me now my Perfect Mate
is manifesting for me now that was his
affirmation and I said do you say these
things he goes oh man I see him about a
million times a day I said did they work
for he says Nah
you know these these things don't work
and I said why do you think they don't
work and he said look at me he says I'm
an engineer I'm a slob he said I I wear
the same clothes to work three out of
five days during the week you know and
and the the bottom line by the time he
finished describing himself to me even
he didn't believe that he was worthy of
his Perfect Mate manifesting for him now
so he was saying the words
but he was not there was the the
underlying emotion and what he was
actually feeding into his his system was
counter to what those words were saying
so it's it's not enough to say the words
when we go into our most ancient and
cherished spiritual Traditions those
words are what become the prayers
and for many people I have and I know
you've heard this as well a lot of
people feel that prayer is broken that
the world doesn't work today the way it
worked in biblical times
that we have lost our power and that we
have no ability to communicate with a
greater power with god with the forces
around us and it's largely because
the secrets the Deep truth of our
relationship
fundamental physics of our relationship
to our world
have been minced and parceled and in
many cases deleted
from the texts leaving us with a sense
that we are essentially powerless beings
and if you are powerless then you are a
victim and if you are a victim you need
a savior and that savior is coming to us
on a silver plate in terms of technology
in terms of political leaders I will
save you if you just do these things
and this is why I say I think one of the
most the most powerful acts and the most
radical act we can do is to think for
ourselves uh original thinking based
upon the Deep truth of our relationship
to our bodies in the earth not based
upon the false assumptions of obsolete
science that permeate our academic world
right now it's one of the reasons I left
Academia it's one of the reasons many of
my colleagues who are in this genre who
are very well respected scientists have
left Academia because they were not
allowed to share with students and in
their writings and their papers what
they had found in their research that
reflects a very different reality now
for me it's it's a uh it's good news
it's a beautiful message of Hope and
possibility uh as a sovereign biological
being
for a system that's based on centralized
power and control it's probably the
worst news they could imagine because it
means we don't need the centralized
power and control I think ultimately
we're all better off by embracing our
own power because it frees us from the
fear of a changing world and we all know
our world my world is changing your
world is changing nor has it ever faster
than we can document it in our
classrooms and textbooks
but the change isn't necessarily bad
until we compare it to what we've known
in the past and this is where the fear
comes in
so the the new discoveries helping us to
understand
we are part of rather than separate from
our world and this is this is where the
affirmations come in so
in I was at the CERN superconducting
super collider in Geneva Switzerland
where the the physics experiments that
are revealing
what happened moments after our universe
began they recreate
the beginning of our universe and then
they're able to document what happened
then to create the laws of physics that
we are experiencing that we're living
under right now
and what they announced in 2012 is that
there is in fact a field
an intelligent field of energy it's a
subtle energy that underlies all of
creation
um before then it was a metaphor or a
lot of people felt like it was a new age
concept you know we are all one
everything is is connected or an
indigenous you know a lot of indigenous
Elders talk about this here's here's
where they got stuck
and I've gone to Scientific conferences
where they'll take their hands and
they'll say oh yeah there's that's
that's no longer controversial there is
a field there's a field out there that
connects all things and their hands go
like this there's a field out there that
connects all things because
subconsciously they're still saying
we're separate from that field right but
here's what the science is showing us
and this this was a game changer for me
uh just a mind blower that every atom
in every molecule and every cell of our
bodies in this very instant so it's not
like it's about to happen it's it's
happening right now every atom is
constantly emerging and collapsing into
that field
and what that says to us is that we are
the field it's not the fields out there
we literally are wrinkles we are
disturbances in this field this this
body
that is held in place by a conscious
awareness as long as I'm breathing on
this Earth
I am a disturbance I'm a localized
Wrinkle in that field and what that
means
is that if I want to bring about change
in my world I don't have to force a
change out there I become that change
and as I have become that change the
field is now reflecting what it is
because I'm part of the field so it's a
subtle but it's a very powerful way a
very different way of thinking you're
not you're not imposing change on the
world around you
you are becoming the change so you're
becoming the abundance you're becoming
uh the love the Gratitude the care
uh the healing you're becoming those
things and that is very different we're
conditioned to ask for them to plead for
them because we're led to feel powerless
in our lives when in fact there are
modalities of ancient prayer that were
edited
from the the religious texts in the
fourth Century by the church they took
they took out the information helping us
to understand that this this deep
relationship leaving us powerless and
and affirmations are essentially a a
form of Prayer
our prayer is a form of affirmation
however you want to look at it where we
are communicating and I want to be
really clear it's not about control it's
not about manipulation it's not about
imposing our will it's about
participating
in the way that this field unfolds and
expresses in in our lives and when you
really begin to get that shift
[Music]
well and it's powerful it's not making
something happen out there and that
means you can't blame
what's out there for your experiences I
I come from a very dysfunctional broken
family and I had to make a choice early
in life
as to whether or not I would and
Community as to whether or not I would
allow that to Define
my my experience to Define my existence
other people around me had the same
experience and they made very different
choices they today continue to blame
their environment their parents their
family their upbringing
for the sad and unfortunate things in
their lives and and that's a path it's
not right wrong good or bad but we have
a choice to make another path
and when we begin as a scientist
beginning to understand these
relationships gave me the reason to
think differently
and it also gave me the reason to test
in my life
if those thoughts are really true or not
what works and what doesn't everything
is possible you know when you believe
that's
the kind of kicker you have to believe
but it's not that hard it's really
pretty easy
our belief creates our entire life
experience and so you can't if I put it
this way you can't experience anything
in life
that is outside of your own beliefs
so and that's that's the case for every
single one of us we really can't
experience anything that's outside of
our beliefs if we can't experience
anything that's outside of our beliefs
what that means is look at all those
hearts that's so beautiful
what that means is there's not really
one world we kind of think there's one
world but there isn't really because
we're all experiencing a world based on
our beliefs and not one of us has the
same beliefs not one of us so that means
there's a different world for every one
of us
so all of your beliefs are held in your
subconscious mind and the subconscious
mind is just a part of your mind there's
the conscious mind and then there's the
subconscious mind who's actual which is
actually higher than the conscious mind
and so we use our conscious mind with
all of the thoughts and everything that
we have our conscious mind is very
present right and so
to create anything
you are using your subconscious mind
your subconscious mind is what is really
what creates if I want to make it really
really simple then I would say the
subconscious mind is what creates
it makes things appear and manifest
things and that's where all of your
beliefs are stored kind of neat huh
because you have to believe to manifest
something and your subconscious mind
creates everything so you can see it's
all kind of perfectly designed
um so now to manifest you have to
believe
and you have to believe that you already
have whatever it is that you want and
the reason that you have to believe you
have it already is because the
subconscious mind is only operating in
the present it can't reason it's just
like a program so if you say for example
um a new car is coming my new car is
coming I'm going to get a new car it's
coming well then it's always going to be
coming right that's the that's the thing
you have to imagine you have it now you
have to go off and you have to test
drive the car you've got to feel the car
smell the car and just then visualize
being in that car and then when you do
that that's how
if you do that enough that's how you'll
come to believe that you actually have
the car and the moment that you believe
there's manifestations instantaneous
so so the other ways to believe is to
affirm over and over and over
um so to be really repetitive for
example
um to visualize and visualizing is
incredibly powerful because when we
close our eyes and we put ourselves in
the picture and you must make sure
you're in the picture and you put
yourself in the picture with whatever it
is that you want and you close your eyes
and you just kind of create this mini
movie honestly
the subconscious mind does not know that
you're imagining it has no idea it just
sees that movie and recreates it it's
like a giant photocopying machine
it will just whatever you hold in your
mind it will
photocopy it warm into the world so
um so if you are thinking about
something in the future it's always
going to be in the future so you have to
imagine that you have it now you have to
act as if and for example
if you wanted to attract a perfect
partner are you acting as if your
perfect partner's here already and so
there are just small things that you can
do that are super super powerful for
example are you sleeping in the middle
of your bed or are you sleeping on one
side of the bed because your partner's
on the other side of the bed
do you have room in your wardrobe for
your perfect partner's clothes is there
room in your bathroom for their
toothbrush and for their things and so
you see they are just little things you
can set the table for two you don't have
to put food on the plate but just
setting the table for two is really
really powerful it's saying my perfect
partner's here already and the
subconscious mind will believe it and
your perfect partner will be attracted
to you through the most incredible
circumstances so if something hasn't
manifested yet and you really really
want it and I I doubt there's anybody
out there who's who wants something and
it hasn't manifested right I mean
um I'll tell you the reason why it
hasn't manifested is because you don't
believe you have it I know you all have
big goals Big Dreams big aspirations
just like I do you've got Ambitions to
become an amazing person to build your
career to create to contribute to give
to be an awesome human being but all of
that is impossible without great habits
set up if you don't have routine and
structure set up in a way that will keep
you on track then you'll you'll fall off
and and having new goals without new
habits is kind of like you know having a
new car without wheels you know the
habits are the wheels they're the things
that make you able to achieve the goals
so you got to have good habits but the
challenge for most people isn't that
knowledge I mean you know you need to
have good habits it's you can't keep the
Habit going right have you ever started
it the new year you're going to get
healthier and you start that habit of
working out on a more regular basis and
then it goes away or you say you know
I'm going to be more kind and more
patient and more awesome to my partner
my lover and you start being nice for
two or three days and then on the fourth
day you're a jerk you know and you're
like why what happened I said I was
gonna be nicer it's that you didn't set
up the most important thing you needed
to maintain a habit so what's the
biggest secret I've learned in almost 20
years in this field it's so simple but
most people don't have it it's called
trigger moments you have to set up
trigger moments to activate your habits
what do I mean by that well let's say
you want to become a better person you
know you want to become more kind more
patient more loving with people now you
can just set that intention or write
that down in your vision in your journal
or set up on a vision board that you
look at once in a while but in
day-to-day life it's not enough you need
things to trigger you to remind you to
be that particular kind of person right
it's almost like if you could have a
little angel speaking in your ear all
day long to tell you what to do and how
to be you'd obviously become better well
that makes sense well let's use that
idea let's use that idea by setting up
alarms on our phones that trigger us to
do the very things we need to do this
can be so basic you're going to laugh
and then also tell you how I literally
taught this to Fortune 50 CEOs and they
said it was the one thing that changed
their life the most dramatically so
let's start with this let's I have a
goal in mind let's say you want to
become more present and calm throughout
the day again you could write that down
on a journal I'm going to be more
present and calm you can meditate in the
morning saying today don't be more
present and calm and you're you could
you could start out with good intentions
but those fall apart without a trigger
moment set up throughout the day to
remind you that so what if you did this
what if you just set up on your phone
three alarms during the day with a label
that said
close your eyes
take 10 deep breaths in remind yourself
to be calm
so let's say you're going through your
day it's crazy right it's 10 a.m and
also Bing your phone goes off you look
down and it says close your eyes take 10
deep breaths and then again it happens
at two o'clock and again it happens at 6
pm and again it happens at 8pm what's
gonna happen you always look at your
phone don't you it's going to go
throughout the day you're going to
forget and the funniest thing is I've
had so many people do this worldwide
we're talking about hundreds of
thousands of people I've taught to do
this hundreds of thousands and they tell
me all the time that changed everything
and you'll think once you set it up that
the next day you you'll you'll forget
about it no that alarm will go off you
forgot you set the dang alarm there it
goes off in your face you're like all
right I'm trying to be calmer and more
present close my eyes take 10 deep
breaths re-ground myself here we go
you can't do it once a day you have to
have moments throughout the day that
trigger you to enact the new Behavior I
know this makes sense to you but it's a
challenge for a lot of people because
they never set those things up so what
if you did it with an alarm
so for example for me on the opposite
Spectrum I don't want to just be calmer
and more present I Want More Energy
throughout the day so here's what I do
one of my big trigger moments is every
time my butt hits a chair I don't care
if I'm on a plane or I was like where
we're shooting here I I wrote a lot of
my books here I wrote the motivation
Manifesto here I wrote The Charge here
and if I'm going to write my butt hits
the chair I grab my phone I open the
timer and I set 50 minutes
now at 50 minutes the timer goes it
starts buzzing and I look at that and I
go oh that's my trigger to get energy so
I stand up I go get some water I take a
glass of water drink it down I do some
stretches and I do some exercise just
really briefly or I'll go for a walk
whatever it is but I'll do something
that usually takes just two to five
minutes then I'll sit back down I'll set
that 50 minute alarm and I'll work
and what that does is every 50 minutes
it triggers me to change how I'm
physically moving it changes my
attention so that throughout the day I'm
continually refreshed so I never have
that two three four o'clock time where
I'm like ah you know why because I'm
triggered my day so that my energy is
maintained throughout the day make sense
right this could be as simple as let's
say you want to be healthier in your
life okay let's set up some trigger
moments for you in this way let's say
every time you drop off the kids on the
way back to that house you stop at the
grocery store and get some fresh produce
that's just a trigger it's like okay did
one thing drop kids off now tied to that
triggered from that action drop kids off
is go to health food store or let's say
you want to get healthier in the morning
one of the easiest ways to help people
maintain a better exercise program is
this
set a trigger you wake up in the morning
your first action is to drink water
put your exercise shoes on it might get
dressed if you were naked just saying so
you get dressed put your shoes on you go
downstairs or you go to the gym and
that's the trigger you woke up you do
these actions nothing interrupts those
actions that's the action and you have
to have those set up one of my other
favorite trigger moments to set up is
door frame triggers what do you remember
that when you walk into a new room
to have a psychological trigger go off
in your mind that you've associated with
that door frame so let me give you an
example if I walk into my house at night
after if I've been working all day and
I'm going to walk in I'm gonna see my
lady I have it so when I ever walk
through the doors of my house three
words repeat off immediately in my mind
because I've done it so many times
consciously I went to the door I said
the three words said three words said
the three words and I did this so many
times and now when I walk through a door
my mind automatically triggers those
three words and I remember to be those
three words so what words would you love
to have describe you as a person that
you would be happy if that was how
people described you what would those
words be have those and now set them up
in your life I teach Executives to do
this as well I have them have a door
frame trigger when they walk into their
office in the morning as soon as they
walk through that door frame they have
boom three words go through their mind
about how they want to be perceived as a
leader I have them set up another door
frame every time they walk into a
meeting into the conference room when
they walk through the doors of the
conference room they have another three
words that trigger off for them and it
just reminds them how to be so these
aren't big crazy things a lot of people
that think they have to completely
change their life what would change your
life completely is setting up more
trigger moments and associations that
when you see something you do this that
when this action is taken then that
happens that when you have the
opportunity to set up alarms on your
phone you set them up so that you're
interrupted in your everyday life to
remind yourself to stick to the habits
to stick to the intention you do that
enough on a continual basis you'll find
yourself in so many ways completely
rejuvenated and I promise you'll stick
to your habits even more and once you do
that you know that everything changes
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome to learn
how to visualize better check the video
right there next to me I think you'll
love it continue to believe I'll see you
there when you teach people how to
create hard coherence and self-regulate
and it makes sense then with a coherent
brain that can hold the image of their
future they can actually then rehearse
who they're going to be they can bring
up the emotions of their future now
here's the cool part